This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vitaantam. We like stories about leaders who have big ideas, who define the odds and pursue their goals with messianic purpose. Think of Winston Churchill in World War II, or Abraham Lincoln during the Civil War. But what happens when a leader's vision is the wrong one? How do we think about people who dream big, only to invite disaster?
这里是《Hidden Brain》，我是 Shankar Vedantam。我们喜欢关于领导者的故事，他们有宏大的构想，敢于挑战不可能，并以救世主般的使命感追求目标。想想二战时期的温斯顿·丘吉尔，或者内战时期的亚伯拉罕·林肯。但当领导者的愿景是错误的时候会发生什么？我们该如何看待那些梦想远大，最终却招致灾难的人？
At such times, we might prefer a more cautious style someone who plays the odds. Those leaders might not score historic triumphs but they rarely cause catastrophes. Thousands of years ago the Greek poet Archylicus summed up this idea. He said, the fox knows many things, but the hedgehog knows one big thing. That has been, that parable has been the subject of much debate over the last 2,500 years, what exactly Archylicus meant. This is a psychologist Phil Tetlock. Various people have offered various interpretations. Some people coming out on the side of the hedgehog saying the hedgehog will trump the fox and other people saying no, it really
在那种时候，我们可能更倾向于一种谨慎的风格，即那些权衡利弊的人。这些领导者可能不会取得历史性的胜利，但他们很少造成灾难。几千年前，希腊诗人阿基洛库斯总结了这个观点。他说，狐狸知道许多事情，但刺猬知道一件大事。这则寓言在过去 2500 年里一直是争论的主题，即阿基洛库斯到底是什么意思。这是心理学家菲尔·泰特洛克。不同的人提出了不同的解读。有些人站在刺猬这一边，说刺猬会胜过狐狸，而另一些人则说不，它实际上
means the fox is going to do better. There are different ways to think about the metaphor, but here's how I see it. If a fox wants dinner, it has many options. It can chase down a hedgehog, it can find something else to eat. It can even go without food for a day. But if you're a hedgehog being chased by a fox, you don't have multiple goals. You have one overarching idea. Don't get eaten. Get Eaton Will Tatlok things this metaphor also describes two different cognitive styles among people Foxes have different strategies for different problems
意味着狐狸会做得更好。关于这个隐喻有不同的思考方式，但我是这样看的。如果狐狸想吃晚餐，它有很多选择。它可以追逐一只刺猬，也可以找别的东西吃。它甚至可以一天不吃东西。但如果你是一只被狐狸追赶的刺猬，你就没有多个目标。你只有一个首要的念头。别被吃掉。别被吃掉。唐·劳布认为这个隐喻也描述了人们的两种不同认知风格。狐狸对不同的问题有不同的策略。
They're comfortable with nuance they can live with contradictions Hedgehogs focus on the big picture. They see every problem through the lens of a single organizing principle. The Hejogs are more parsimonious, more decisive. In most MBA programs, they probably be viewed as better leadership material. This week on Hidden Brain, we're listening back to our May 2017 show that tells the story of a hedgehog, a surgeon who changed the world in daring ways. His bold style made him a pioneer in what is today become the transgender movement.
他们对细微差别感到自在，他们能与矛盾共存。刺猬专注于大局。他们通过单一组织原则的视角看待每一个问题。刺猬更节俭，更果断。在大多数 MBA 项目中，他们可能被视为更好的领导人才。本周在《Hidden Brain》节目中，我们将回顾我们 2017 年 5 月的节目，讲述一个刺猬的故事，一位以大胆方式改变世界的医生。他大胆的风格使他成为当今跨性别运动的先驱。
It also propelled him to create one of the world's first international medical missions. Like other hedgehogs, this surgeon experienced outside success. Until one day, he didn't. It's just that God damn disaster. An awful thing. Greatness and tragedy. This week on Hidden Brain. Sandy Stone was born in 1936 in the midst of the Great Depression. Her parents gave her a Hebrew name. It was there like Ben Nautan.
这也促使他创建了世界上首批国际医疗援助团之一。像其他刺猬一样，这位医生经历了巨大的成功。直到有一天，他没有成功。那简直是一场该死的灾难。一件可怕的事情。伟大与悲剧。本周在《Hidden Brain》节目中。桑迪·斯通于 1936 年出生在大萧条时期。她的父母给了她一个希伯来名字。那是 Zellig Ben Nautan。
Zellig Ben Nautan, a boy's name. That's because her parents thought she was a boy. But from a very early age, she knew she was a girl. This was a long time ago, decades before the modern trans movement. When Sandy was a child, there were no words, no language, to describe what she knew about herself. It was lonely, it was disorienting, it was puzzling, confusing, scary,
Zellig Ben Nautan，一个男孩的名字。那是因为她的父母以为她是男孩。但从很小的时候起，她就知道自己是个女孩。那是很久以前的事了，在现代跨性别运动出现几十年前。当桑迪还是个孩子的时候，没有词汇，没有语言来描述她对自己所知的。那是孤独的，令人迷失方向的，令人困惑的，混乱的，可怕的，
it was all of those things. It stayed like that for Sandy, all the way into adulthood. She went to school, became a recording engineer, moved to the Bay Area. All the while, everyone thought she was a man. She kept searching for help. In the San Francisco phone book she found a promising lead. It was a group for gay men. When she called, the
那是所有这些感觉。对于桑迪来说，这种情况一直持续到成年。她去上学，成为了一名录音工程师，搬到了湾区。一直以来，每个人都以为她是男人。她一直在寻找帮助。在旧金山的电话簿里，她找到了一个有希望的线索。那是一个男同性恋团体。当她打电话时，他们
asked if she was gay. She said she wasn't. So they sent her away and told her to try another group. The outfit they recommended surprised Sandy. It was a San Francisco police department. It turned out that the police department was running a counseling unit of sorts, which they did for the population of transgender people that lived in the San Francisco tenderloin, which was sort of the down and outskid row section of town that tended to collect people who couldn't afford to live anywhere else or who had run out of options. Trans people who ended up in the tenderloin were at high risk for drug addiction and prostitution. They were social outcasts. When Sandy got in touch with the police to ask for help, the first thing they did was to dissuade her from acting on her feelings. And they actually tried to discourage me by taking on a tour that reminded me of Dante being led down into the lower circles of hell.
问她是不是同性恋。她说她不是。所以他们把她打发走了，告诉她去试试另一个团体。他们推荐的那个机构让桑迪感到惊讶。那是旧金山警察局。原来警察局经营着一种咨询部门，他们为居住在旧金山田德隆区的跨性别群体提供服务，那里算是城里贫困潦倒的贫民窟，往往聚集着那些负担不起其他地方生活或走投无路的人。最终落脚在田德隆区的跨性别者面临着很高的药物成瘾和卖淫风险。他们是社会弃儿。当桑迪联系警察寻求帮助时，他们做的第一件事就是劝阻她不要根据自己的感觉行事。他们实际上试图通过带我参观来劝阻我，那让我想起但丁被带入地狱下层的情景。
They really showed me the worst of everything and then said, are you sure you still want to go ahead with what you were thinking of? And to be perfectly honest, I wasn't quite sure what I was thinking of. I was just trying to collect information. And I think it would be safe to say that that's what we were all doing at that time. Still, the referral to the police turned out to be a stroke of luck. The cops told her that a center at Stanford University had recently started performing what would then called sex change operations.
他们真的向我展示了所有最糟糕的一面，然后说，你确定还要继续你所想的那样做吗？老实说，我并不完全确定我在想什么。我只是试图收集信息。我认为可以肯定地说，那时我们都在做同样的事情。尽管如此，警察的推荐竟然成了一种幸运。警察告诉她，斯坦福大学的一个中心最近开始进行当时所谓的变性手术。
They didn't refer me to Stanford as much as talk about it as the great unattainable goal, the great, beautiful, shining star in the sky. After years of suffering and loneliness and confusion, the Stanford program felt like a beacon. Sandy felt she might finally have a chance to live a more honest, satisfying life. But first, she had to convince the gatekeeper, who stood between her and the person she wanted to become. He ran what was then called the Gender Disphoria Program at Stanford. His name was Don Lob.
他们与其说是把我推荐给斯坦福，不如说是把它当作一个伟大的、遥不可及的目标，天空中那颗伟大、美丽、闪亮的星星来谈论。经过多年的痛苦、孤独和困惑，斯坦福的项目感觉就像一座灯塔。桑迪觉得她终于有机会过上更诚实、更令人满意的生活。但首先，她必须说服那个站在她和她想成为的人之间的守门人。他负责斯坦福大学当时所谓的性别焦虑症项目。他的名字叫唐·劳布。
The gatekeeper of Stanford's Gender Disphoria Program was a hedgehog. From a very early age, he had a big picture right there. He wanted to help people. He wanted to help a lot of people. As a small child, when kids in his school were asked to donate money to a charity, his classmates contributed a dime. Don worked in a vegetable garden an entire summer to raise a whopping $10. Now, I got a letter, a preserved letter from it that my mother wrote to some of her friends saying, done, he's done something that nobody has ever done.
斯坦福性别焦虑症项目的守门人是一只刺猬。从很小的时候起，他就有一个宏大的蓝图。他想帮助别人。他想帮助很多人。小时候，当学校里的孩子被要求为慈善机构捐款时，他的同学们捐了一角钱。唐整个夏天都在菜园里干活，筹集了惊人的 10 美元。现在，我有一封保存下来的信，是我母亲写给她的朋友们的，说唐，他做了一件从来没有人做过的事。
Don's father feared his little boy was consumed with being a doogutter, that he would turn out to be a failure at business. His father was right. Don Lob became a doctor. When he came to Stanford in the 1960s, he was a young, ambitious plastic surgeon, very much an awe of his prize-winning colleagues. Coming to Stanford, I was overshadowed by the hugeness of what people were doing, the importance of it. So I knew that I had to do something,
唐的父亲担心他的小儿子沉迷于做善事，将来会在生意上失败。他父亲是对的。唐·劳布成为了一名医生。当他在 20 世纪 60 年代来到斯坦福时，他是一位年轻、雄心勃勃的整形外科医生，非常敬畏他那些获奖的同事。来到斯坦福，我被人们所做的事情的宏大和重要性所掩盖。所以我知道我必须做点什么，
like maybe, you know, I got to do this somewhere along the line because everybody else here is doing it. Dawn was looking for a place to make his mark. One day, a colleague walked out of an examination room and came up to him. When Dawn, I'm watching, I see a patient. It's a good case.
就像，你知道，我必须在某个时候做这件事，因为这里的每个人都在做。唐一直在寻找一个能让他留下印记的地方。有一天，一位同事走出检查室，向他走来。唐，我在看一个病人。这是一个很好的病例。
You might not like it. It's a sex change. Remember, this was 1968. I said, Dave, send that patient away. I'm a Catholic boy from the Midwest, and I'm at Stanford. We don't do those things. But Dan's colleague insisted he meet the patient.
你可能不会喜欢它。这是一个变性手术。记住，那是 1968 年。我说，戴夫，把那个病人打发走。我是来自中西部的天主教男孩，我在斯坦福。我们不做那种事。但唐的同事坚持要他见见那个病人。
To be clear, this patient was not Sandy Stone. He said, do me a favor and go in that room. I just went in the room and talked to the patient and I said, now why do you want a section? She said, well, I was born and this is what I should be. I said, well, when did you decide that she said, I didn't decide it? This is what I was born with from day one. This patient was a pioneer.
需要说明的是，这个病人不是桑迪·斯通。他说，帮我个忙，进那个房间。我只是走进房间和病人谈了谈，我说，你为什么想要变性？她说，嗯，我出生时就是这样，这就是我应该成为的样子。我说，那你什么时候决定的？她说，我没有决定。我从第一天起就是这样出生的。这个病人是一位先驱。
No one on the west coast had received what's come to be done today as gender reassignment surgery or gender confirmation surgery. In fact, the surgery had been rarely performed across the whole world. Don was an unlikely choice of doctor. He was, by his own account, a prim man from the Midwest. But although Don initially blanched the idea of gender reassignment surgery, he felt a chevare of excitement. He didn't send the patient away.
西海岸没有人接受过今天所说的性别重置手术或性别确认手术。事实上，这种手术在全世界范围内都很少进行。唐是一个不太可能的医生人选。按照他自己的说法，他是一个来自中西部的古板男人。但尽管唐最初对性别重置手术的想法感到退缩，但他感到一种兴奋的颤栗。他没有把病人打发走。
Instead, he went looking for information. He consulted with psychiatrists and a few surgeons around the world who'd already performed this kind of surgery. What prompted you, this sort of, you know, Catholic doctor from the Midwest, to basically take this on? It seems like an unlikely fit. It was a wonderful opportunity to do a big thing and to help a lot of people. Altruism and ambition were always tightly woven in Don's identity. He wasn't interested in superficial cosmetic work, he wanted to change the world.
相反，他开始寻找信息。他咨询了精神科医生和世界上少数几位已经进行过此类手术的外科医生。是什么促使你，这个来自中西部的天主教医生，基本上承担起这件事？这看起来不太合适。这是一个做大事并帮助很多人的绝佳机会。利他主义和野心总是紧密地交织在唐的身份中。他对肤浅的美容工作不感兴趣，他想改变世界。
He decided to take the leap. In November 1968, Don Law performed California's first gender reassignment surgery. That we were more than prepared for all the things that might happen. And a surgery went fine. It took about three and a half hours and we did it with the skin graft method and no problem. Don soon became one of the world's leading experts on gender reassignment surgery. He started a program. His reputation grew. A reputation for being a good surgeon and a tough gatekeeper.
他决定迈出这一步。1968 年 11 月，唐·劳布进行了加州首例性别重置手术。我们对可能发生的所有事情都做了充分的准备。手术进行得很顺利。大约花了三个半小时，我们用了皮肤移植法，没有问题。唐很快成为世界上领先的性别重置手术专家之一。他启动了一个项目。他的名声越来越大。一个作为好外科医生和严厉守门人的名声。
He turned away many people because he felt they weren't good candidates for surgery. Sandy Stone vividly remembers her first appointment with him in the mid-70s. I go in and sit down and Don is behind his desk and he's wearing his white coat and he's very distinguished looking and calm and very friendly and open. And he says, well, what can I do for you? And I say the first thing that comes into my head, which is, I think I'm a woman. Now the scene we have is Don behind his desk and me. I have a long black beard and wild black hair. I'm wearing a blue shirt, jeans, and engineers boots. I do not exactly look like I'm thinking of myself as a stereotypical woman. And Don looks at me and says, really? And I say,
他拒绝了许多人，因为他觉得他们不是手术的好人选。桑迪·斯通生动地记得 70 年代中期她与他的第一次预约。我走进去坐下，唐坐在办公桌后面，穿着白大褂，看起来非常尊贵、冷静、非常友好和开放。他说，嗯，我能为你做什么？我说出了脑海中浮现的第一件事，那就是，我想我是个女人。现在我们看到的场景是唐坐在办公桌后面，而我。我留着长长的黑胡子，头发凌乱。我穿着蓝色衬衫、牛仔裤和工程师靴。我看起来并不完全像是在把自己当作一个典型的女人。唐看着我说，真的吗？我说，
what should I do? I mean, I'm totally, I'm completely open to anything. I really don't know what I should do, what direction I should move in, what's right, what's wrong, and I'm looking to Donald to tell me. And in my memory of the thing Donald then says, well the first thing you should do is lose the beard. That was the beginning of Sandy's long transformative journey. It was a tough journey. Don wanted Sandy to be sure she was making the right decision. So before he would even consider surgery, Sandy says he told her she would have to live openly and fully as a woman for one full year. It was a requirement based on the reality of the time. No one, not Sandy, nor Don, knew what might come from these surgeries in the long term.
我该怎么办？我的意思是，我完全、彻底地对任何事情持开放态度。我真的不知道我该做什么，我应该向哪个方向发展，什么是对的，什么是错的，我指望唐纳德告诉我。在我的记忆中，唐纳德然后说，嗯，你首先应该做的是把胡子刮掉。那是桑迪漫长转变旅程的开始。这是一段艰难的旅程。唐想让桑迪确定她做出了正确的决定。所以在他考虑手术之前，桑迪说他告诉她，她必须以女性身份公开、充分地生活整整一年。这是一个基于当时现实的要求。没有人，无论是桑迪还是唐，都不知道这些手术从长远来看会带来什么。
These were early days. It was all a bit of an experiment, a shot in the dark. It was fraught. It was fraught for everyone. And it was fraught because at that time it was not clear what would happen later. We didn't have very many examples of transgender people who had had surgery, who went on to have fulfilling lives, and lived to tell about it, which is to say came back later and reported back to the program. They were experimenting on the fringe of what both medicine and society thought was acceptable.
那是早期。这一切都有点像实验，盲人摸象。这充满了风险。对每个人来说都充满了风险。之所以充满风险，是因为当时还不清楚以后会发生什么。我们没有太多接受过手术的跨性别者的例子，他们后来过上了充实的生活，并活着讲述了这一切，也就是说，后来回来并向项目报告。他们是在医学和社会认为可接受的边缘进行实验。
Don was taking risks with his professional reputation. Sandy was taking risks with his professional reputation. Sandy was taking risks with her life. There was one moment Sandy says when she and Don clashed, the conflict boiled down to their cognitive styles. At some point he asked me if I were 100% committed to wanting surgery. surgery. And I said, no, I'm not. I'm probably 99.9%. I think anyone who's 100% committed to anything is probably crazy. You have to have some reservations in life. You have to have an overview of everything that you're doing and have alternative plans of what you're looking for doesn't work out. And Don said, well, in that case, you're not eligible for surgery.
唐在拿他的职业声誉冒险。桑迪在拿她的生命冒险。桑迪说，有一次她和唐发生了冲突，冲突归结为他们的认知风格。在某个时候，他问我是否 100% 承诺想要手术。我说，不，我不是。我大概是 99.9%。我认为任何对任何事情 100% 承诺的人可能都疯了。你在生活中必须有一些保留意见。你必须对你所做的一切有一个概览，并对你所追求的事情如果行不通有替代计划。唐说，嗯，那样的话，你不符合手术资格。
You have to be 100% committed. It took a mediated session with Don's assistant for the two of them to resolve the conflict. But the incident reveals something about the way a hedgehog moves through the world. Hedgehogs are decisive. Don could not understand anything less than 100% commitment, even if the 0.1% of doubt was simply a way to say, I'm human. How can I be absolutely sure? Sandy tells another story of a time she came in for an appointment wearing jeans and a t-shirt.
你必须 100% 承诺。经过唐的助手调解，两人才解决了冲突。但这件事揭示了刺猬在世界上行走方式的一些东西。刺猬是果断的。唐无法理解任何少于 100% 的承诺，即使那 0.1% 的怀疑仅仅是一种表达方式，即我是人类。我怎么能绝对确定呢？桑迪讲了另一个故事，有一次她穿着牛仔裤和 T 恤去赴约。
Don asked her why she wasn't dressed like a woman. He'd missed the bell-bottom jeans and tie-dye revolution happening right outside his window. It was the kind of thing that could have led to a fight, except for one thing. Sandy understood where Dawn was coming from. She knew that underneath the tough exterior, he really wanted to help. And not just in a medical sense. More than anything, Don wanted Sandy to live a life where she didn't feel like an outcast. He wanted his people to be totally remarkable, to just fit in, to be able to live their
唐问她为什么没有穿得像个女人。他错过了窗外正在发生的喇叭裤和扎染革命。这本可能导致一场争吵，但有一件事除外。桑迪理解唐的出发点。她知道在坚硬的外表下，他真的想帮忙。而且不仅仅是在医学意义上。最重要的是，唐希望桑迪过上一种她不会觉得自己是弃儿的生活。他希望他的人民是完全非凡的，只是融入其中，能够过上他们的
lives, to be able to be inconspicuous and just get along and that's a good thing to want for 99% of your waking day is just to be able to live your life, to be able to live with other people and and not rub people the wrong way. When I interviewed Sandy, I told her that her story reminded me of another case that Don told me about. It's interesting because I don't first came to my attention because of another case involving cleft lip surgery and it's so striking that as you're saying this I'm sort of hearing echoes of that other work as well. There's a drive that he had to just help people to essentially live what he would think of as being a normal life, a life that they're not ostracized, a life that they're not feeling like they're outcasts, that they're functioning, they can get
生活，能够不引人注目，只是相处融洽，这对于你清醒时间的 99% 来说是一个很好的愿望，就是能够过你的生活，能够与其他人一起生活，并且不惹恼别人。当我采访桑迪时，我告诉她，她的故事让我想起了唐告诉我的另一个案例。这很有趣，因为唐最初引起我的注意是因为另一个涉及唇裂手术的案例，这太引人注目了，当你这样说时，我似乎也听到了那项工作的回声。他有一种动力，就是去帮助人们基本上过上他认为的正常生活，一种他们不会被排斥的生活，一种他们不会觉得自己是弃儿的生活，他们是有功能的，他们可以获得
an education, if they're a child, that they can get a job, if they're an adult, that they can be happy. And I feel there's something, something actually very midwestern about that idea. That's the word that word you said is correct. Don wanted people to be happy. Don did it professionally. His job was was to help people to be happy. And for that, I owe him a lifetime debt. I would not have done anything I think that I did after the 1980s, if it weren't for Don Laub, or the 70s, rather, if it weren't for Don Laub. Sandy went on to become a prominent writer and theorist, and eventually helped found the academic discipline of transgender studies.
教育，如果他们是孩子，他们可以找到工作，如果他们是成年人，他们可以快乐。我觉得这个想法中有些东西，实际上非常中西部。你说得对，那个词是正确的。唐希望人们快乐。唐是专业地做这件事的。他的工作就是帮助人们快乐。为此，我欠他一生的债。如果不是因为唐·劳布，我不会做任何我认为我在 80 年代之后做的事情，或者说是 70 年代，如果不是因为唐·劳布。桑迪后来成为了一位杰出的作家和理论家，并最终帮助创立了跨性别研究这一学术学科。
When she considers Dawn's influence on her life, she homes in on his willingness to pursue a big idea with single-minded purpose. Do you go for the big one or do you accept something less? And many of us accept something less because we don't want to take the risk. And then we may go through life, maybe, maybe we'll be happy with our measure. Or maybe we'll say, what if I had gone for what I really wanted? What would that have been like? Maybe I would have died. Yeah, maybe I would have.
当她考虑唐对她生活的影响时，她专注于他以单一目的追求宏大构想的意愿。你是去追求那个宏大的目标，还是接受一些次要的东西？我们中的许多人接受次要的东西，因为我们不想冒险。然后我们可能会度过一生，也许，也许我们会对我们的衡量标准感到满意。或者我们可能会说，如果我追求了我真正想要的呢？那会是什么样子？也许我会死。是的，也许我会。
But I didn't. I beat the odds. And I went on to be glory as lay happy. That's something in life. And Don brought that to many people. I don't see how one could do better than that. Don's leap into the unknown, his willingness to bet his professional reputation on a big idea, his confidence in his own judgment, it had all paid off. The hedgehog had won.
但我没有。我战胜了困难。我继续过着快乐的生活。那是生活中的一件事。唐给很多人带来了这一点。我不明白一个人怎么能做得比这更好。唐跃入未知，他愿意拿自己的职业声誉去赌一个宏大的构想，他对自己的判断充满信心，这一切都得到了回报。刺猬赢了。
But pursuing a big idea with determination doesn't always pay off, and when a hedgehog fails, the fall can be painful. Don Lobb knows about that part of the story, too. Stay with us. According to the ancient Greek poet Archylikus, the fox knows many things, but the hedgehog knows one big thing. Psychologists feel tech locks as the metaphor describes two kinds of people. Small picture tacticians are foxes. Big picture strategists are hedgehogs.
但以决心追求宏大的构想并不总是有回报，当刺猬失败时，跌落可能是痛苦的。唐·劳布也知道故事的那一部分。请留下来。根据古希腊诗人阿基洛库斯的说法，狐狸知道许多事情，但刺猬知道一件大事。心理学家菲尔·泰特洛克说这个隐喻描述了两种人。小图景战术家是狐狸。大图景战略家是刺猬。
Before Don Lobb became a world-renowned gender reassignment surgeon, he had another big idea. It started this way. One day, a colleague asked him if he could help with the surgery. The patient was a child from Mexico. This was a 14-year-old boy who had no other deformity than his cleft lip and palate.
在唐·劳布成为世界著名的性别重置外科医生之前，他有另一个宏大的构想。它是这样开始的。有一天，一位同事问他是否可以帮忙做手术。病人是一个来自墨西哥的孩子。这是一个 14 岁的男孩，除了唇腭裂外没有其他畸形。
But because of it, the boy was shunned. A group of priests had driven him north all the way to Stanford to get him help. Don immediately understood that the cleft lip wasn't just a medical problem. He had not gone to school, he had no educational advancement, he had no friends. The surgery to repair the cleft lip and pallet was simple and quick. It was so easy and it gave this child a real chance in life. Don says performing the surgery made him feel really good. As someone with deep religious roots and a Catholic education that emphasized helping the poor, Don felt this was the kind of patient he wanted to serve. He turned to the priest who brought the boy from Mexico.
但正因为如此，这个男孩被排斥了。一群牧师开车把他一路向北送到斯坦福寻求帮助。唐立刻明白，唇裂不仅仅是一个医学问题。他没有上过学，没有受过教育，没有朋友。修复唇腭裂的手术简单而快捷。它太容易了，给了这个孩子一个真正的人生机会。唐说进行手术让他感觉非常好。作为一个有着深厚宗教根基和强调帮助穷人的天主教教育背景的人，唐觉得这就是他想要服务的病人类型。他转向带男孩从墨西哥来的牧师。
They asked him are there other patients in Mexico? Like this? They said the place is full of them. So we bought an airplane ticket and went down to Mexicali and asked for a clinic. Just like that, where a fox may have calculated the odds, considered the upside and the downside, the hedgehog simply picked up and went. In Mexicali, dawn found a dusty border town in the desert where the people were very poor. I mean most of the houses were made of packing crates at that time and there was no paving in Mexicali of 200,000 people. Mexicali's main medical facility was an old wood home.
他们问他墨西哥还有其他病人吗？像这样的？他们说那个地方到处都是。所以我们买了一张飞机票，去了墨西卡利，要求建立一个诊所。就这样，当狐狸可能计算过胜算，考虑过利弊时，刺猬只是收拾行装就出发了。在墨西卡利，唐发现了一个沙漠中尘土飞扬的边境小镇，那里的人们非常贫穷。我的意思是，当时大多数房子都是用包装箱做的，20 万人口的墨西卡利没有铺设路面。墨西卡利的主要医疗设施是一座旧木屋。
It had a dirt floor for part of it. With the back part of the clinic was used to raise fighting cocks. A rational fox may have calculated the risks and back down, not done. He recruited local health officials to get word out that they would be providing free surgeries for children with cleft lips and burn scars. The clinic was quickly packed. It was 10.30 in the morning. Then that desert, there had not been rain there for three years. The hot in the morning, it was about 106 degrees already.
它的一部分是泥地。诊所的后部被用来饲养斗鸡。理性的狐狸可能已经计算过风险并退缩了，但唐没有。他招募了当地的卫生官员，传达他们将为唇裂和烧伤疤痕的儿童提供免费手术的消息。诊所很快就挤满了人。那是早上 10 点 30 分。在那个沙漠里，那里已经三年没有下雨了。早上很热，已经有 106 华氏度了。
You couldn't touch anything metal because you'd burn your hand. The first patient I saw it was sitting there with the bag on I just had two little peep holes. I said, what's with the, why the bag? Behind those peep holes, the boy was hiding his face in shame. Don asked if he could take a look. So he got the bag off and he had a burn scar to pull this island down. A simple thing to repair.
你不能碰任何金属，因为你会烫伤手。我看到的第一个病人坐在那里，戴着袋子，只有两个小窥视孔。我说，这是怎么回事，为什么要戴袋子？在那些窥视孔后面，男孩羞愧地藏着他的脸。唐问他能不能看看。所以他把袋子拿下来，他有一个烧伤疤痕把眼睑拉了下来。一个简单的修复手术。
As with Sandy, Don wanted to make the little boy, Andromarkable. He wanted him to lead an ordinary life, unmarked by stigma and shame. That first trip was just a fact-finding mission, a way to see if there was a need. By the time Don went back to Stanford, a plan had formed in his mind. He wanted to recruit the best doctors from the United States and fly them to Mexico to perform free surgeries on children with birth defects. He recruited surgical residents to join skilled surgeons on the trips, he found pilots willing to transport medical equipment. Headsogs have charisma. They can see the shining city on the hill so clearly
和桑迪一样，唐想让那个小男孩变得非凡。他希望他过上普通的生活，不被耻辱和羞愧所标记。那第一次旅行只是一个事实调查任务，看看是否有需求。当唐回到斯坦福时，一个计划在他脑海中形成了。他想从美国招募最好的医生，并把他们飞到墨西哥，为患有先天缺陷的儿童进行免费手术。他招募了外科住院医生加入熟练的外科医生团队参加旅行，他找到了愿意运送医疗设备的飞行员。刺猬有魅力。他们能如此清晰地看到山上的闪亮城市
that everyone around them starts to see it too. Everybody jumped on it. I had a hide when I go to the hospital because people wanted to get in on this. In 1966, the official medical missions began. Now, it's important to remember that at this time, the idea of plastic surgeons going abroad to provide free surgery was almost unheard of.
以至于周围的每个人都开始看到了。每个人都加入了。我得躲起来，当我去医院时，因为人们想参与进来。1966 年，官方医疗任务开始了。现在，重要的是要记住，在当时，整形外科医生出国提供免费手术的想法几乎是闻所未闻的。
There were fewer parameters of how international aid organizations should operate. Don was flying by the seat of his pants. Every few months the doctors would descend on Mexicali. They'd throw themselves into four marathon days of back-to-back surgeries and consultations. Over the years they'd come back, again and again, performing more than 2,000 surgeries in all. One of Don's first patients was a little boy named Eugenio. He was the boy who'd worn the bag over his head. Don repaired the scarred eyelid and still remembers the boy's first reaction. We heard a very nice, huge smile.
关于国际援助组织应该如何运作的参数很少。唐是在摸着石头过河。每隔几个月，医生们就会降临墨西卡利。他们会投入到四天马拉松式的背靠背手术和咨询中。多年来，他们一次又一次地回来，总共进行了 2000 多次手术。唐的第一批病人之一是一个叫尤金尼奥的小男孩。他就是那个头上戴着袋子的男孩。唐修复了有疤痕的眼睑，至今仍记得男孩的第一次反应。我们听到了一个非常好的、巨大的微笑。
On a follow-up trip, Don tracked Eugene, you're done. He shook hands and everything like that, even as a young kid. And he said, I have friends at school, though. Don loved it. It's a real happiness. It's a source of happiness is the best description. If anything, Don and I would describe it as a very... And I think he would accept it as I think it was a very sort of a missionary zeal.
在后续的旅行中，唐追踪了尤金尼奥。他握手等等，即使作为一个小孩子。他说，不过我在学校有朋友了。唐很喜欢。这是一种真正的幸福。幸福的源泉是最好的描述。如果有的话，唐和我都会把它描述为一种……我认为他会接受它，因为我认为这是一种非常传教士般的热情。
This is plastic surgeon Howard Holdeness. He was part of the team of residents helping perform surgeries in Mexicali. Howard says that Don's vision drove the whole team. I think he felt very close to trying to do things that not only practiced medicine and it's all of its forms of science and everything, but the art of medicine and some of the spiritual aspects of being a good doctor. He was doing more than surgeries. Dawn was developing a program that could set an example
这是整形外科医生霍华德·霍尔德内斯。他是帮助在墨西卡利进行手术的住院医生团队的一员。霍华德说，唐的愿景驱动了整个团队。我认为他觉得非常接近于尝试做一些事情，不仅是实践医学及其所有形式的科学和一切，而且是医学的艺术以及作为一名好医生的一些精神层面。他做的不仅仅是手术。唐正在开发一个可以树立榜样
for others to follow around the world. One day, about two years into the Mexico program, a woman arrived at the clinic with her young son. His name was Salvador. Compared with the other patients, Salvador had a more severe birth defect. He had bilateral clefts, two clefts rather than one. When you have this bilateral, the muscles are cut twice. So when you smile, they pull out. If they're repaired, they pull in.
供世界各地其他人效仿的项目。有一天，在墨西哥项目进行大约两年后，一位妇女带着她的小儿子来到诊所。他的名字叫萨尔瓦多。与其他病人相比，萨尔瓦多的先天缺陷更严重。他有双侧裂，两个裂口而不是一个。当你患有这种双侧裂时，肌肉被切断了两次。所以当你微笑时，它们会向外拉。如果修复了，它们会向内拉。
So every time he would have a facial expression, it would be awful. You'd see these teeth on both sides. Salvador was a perfect candidate for surgery. That is, until a doctor on the team gave the boy a thorough physical and listened to his heart with a stethoscope. His mother brought him in and the pediatrician listened and he was the heart sounds. These were not normal sounds. The boy's heart had a hole in it.
所以每次他有面部表情时，都会很可怕。你会看到两边的牙齿。萨尔瓦多是手术的完美人选。也就是说，直到团队中的一名医生对男孩进行了彻底的体检并用听诊器听了他的心脏。他的母亲带他进来，儿科医生听了，那是心音。这些不是正常的声音。男孩的心脏有一个洞。
The risk of proceeding with surgery was small but potentially fatal. They gave the mother the bad news. So Don and his team turned away the mother and the little boy. I should say here that we're going only on Don's account of what happened, the medical records from that era are incomplete and we weren't able to find the mother. A few months after sending the child away, Don and his team were back in Mexico. The mother and her son were waiting for them again. Salvador, she told him, was shunned. He had no friends. Other children called him El Monstre. The monster. The mother said, this child has no chance in life. You got to fix it.
进行手术的风险很小，但可能是致命的。他们给了母亲坏消息。所以唐和他的团队拒绝了母亲和小男孩。我应该在这里说明，我们只是根据唐对所发生事情的描述，那个时代的医疗记录不完整，我们无法找到那位母亲。在把孩子打发走几个月后，唐和他的团队又回到了墨西哥。母亲和她的儿子又在等他们了。她说，萨尔瓦多被排斥了。他没有朋友。其他孩子叫他“怪物”。母亲说，这个孩子在生活中没有机会。你必须修复它。
Don's heart went out to the little boy. He explained the danger again. The risk was small, but it did mean that things could go seriously wrong. Don held the stethoscope up to the mother's ears. Listen, she can hear it. Whoosh, whoosh, whoosh. So the answer again was no. More months passed. Don returned to the clinic, so did the mother. Please doctor, can you see that child has no life? This was a critical moment. Don could again have said no. Medical protocol said that was the right call.
唐对这个小男孩深表同情。他再次解释了危险。风险很小，但这确实意味着事情可能会严重出错。唐把听诊器举到母亲的耳朵上。听，她能听到。呼呼，呼呼，呼呼。所以答案还是不行。又过了几个月。唐回到了诊所，母亲也来了。求求你医生，你能看出那个孩子没有生活吗？这是一个关键时刻。唐本可以再次说不。医疗规程说那是正确的决定。
But Don also knew that without surgery, Salvador would always be an outcast. Could he have tried to take the boy back to Stanford where hot surgeons could have assisted with his care? Maybe. take the boy back to Stanford where hot surgeons could have assisted with his care, maybe. But that would have been complicated, expensive, and a drain on critical resources from the project in Mexico, resources that were helping hundreds of other children. So Don did what Don always did. He took a look at the child, took a deep breath, and said, okay, we'll do it.
但唐也知道，没有手术，萨尔瓦多将永远是一个弃儿。他本可以尝试把男孩带回斯坦福，那里有顶尖的外科医生可以协助他的护理吗？也许。但那会很复杂、昂贵，并且会消耗墨西哥项目中关键的资源，这些资源正在帮助数百名其他儿童。所以唐做了唐总是做的事。他看了看孩子，深吸了一口气，说，好吧，我们做吧。
I feel like that's why I existed is for this judgment. I mean, I'm not there to take care of little pimples. I'm there to do the tough cases. So this was putting it right on the line. You got to do it or put your tail between your legs and get out of there. It's been nearly 50 years since Don Law performed that surgery on a six year old boy
我觉得这就是我存在的原因，就是为了这个判断。我的意思是，我不是为了处理小粉刺而存在的。我是为了处理棘手的病例。所以这是把它放在了线上。你必须做，或者夹着尾巴逃走。距离唐·劳布对一个六岁男孩进行那次手术已经快 50 年了
in Mexicale, Mexico. He's had thousands 50 years since Don Law performed that surgery on a six-year-old boy in Mexico, Mexico. He's had thousands of patients since then, but the details of that day are still vivid in his mind. The morning of the surgery, the boy went through the standard pre-surgery lab tests and check-up, and Ivy was started, and he received extra glucose in case his blood sugar was low from stomach worms, and then the boy walked by himself into the operating room. And he gets on the operating table himself. Because he trusts the whole world.
在墨西哥墨西卡利。从那以后他有成千上万的病人，但那一天的细节在他脑海中依然清晰。手术那天早上，男孩通过了标准的术前实验室检查和体检，开始了静脉注射，他接受了额外的葡萄糖，以防他因胃虫而血糖过低，然后男孩独自走进手术室。他自己上了手术台。因为他信任整个世界。
The surgery began. First the child was anesthetized. So that went fine, went perfect, no problem at all. Then Dawn and his team began the surgery. When we were operating, everything was going perfect. And then, just like that, it wasn't. And I see jealous and boys. We have no pulse.
手术开始了。首先孩子被麻醉了。所以一切都很顺利，完美，一点问题都没有。然后唐和他的团队开始了手术。当我们手术时，一切都很完美。然后，就这样，不再完美了。我看到……我们没有脉搏。
They tried everything. CPR, medicine to jumpstart the heart, nothing worked. Dan suspected a blood clot. The boy was dead. They put away their surgical tools. They wheeled the body to the morgue. All the while, Dan's heart was starting to race. He was working in a foreign country,
他们尝试了一切。心肺复苏，让心脏跳动的药物，什么都不起作用。唐怀疑是血栓。男孩死了。他们收起了手术工具。他们把尸体推到了太平间。一直以来，唐的心脏开始加速。他在一个外国工作，
and he had made a risky judgment call in violation of medical protocol And my mind is going a thousand miles a minute Why am I here in Mexico? Why did I get into this what the hell is the matter with you? Here you are in a foreign country you can end up in jail. It's just a goddamn disaster. An awful thing. And of course, there was the boy's mother waiting anxiously outside for news of her son. Don remembers stepping out of the operating room and walking up to her.
他做出了违反医疗规程的冒险判断。我的大脑在飞速运转。我为什么在墨西哥？我为什么要卷入这个，你到底怎么了？你身处一个外国，你最终可能会进监狱。这简直是一场该死的灾难。一件可怕的事情。当然，还有男孩的母亲在外面焦急地等待着她儿子的消息。唐记得走出手术室，向她走去。
He told her they'd been complications that they had tried hard, but the boy had died. The mother began to sob, but then Don says, she did something surprising. She asked him why he was upset. She said, you should be happy because the child is seeing God with a complete face. Don had expected accusation and anger. is seeing God with a complete face. Don had expected accusation and anger. Instead he encountered a mother who leaned heavily on her faith. Don said she was comforted by the thought that her child was now repaired and beautiful and at home with God. Salvador was finally at peace. Don stared at the mother.
他告诉她有并发症，他们尽力了，但男孩已经死了。母亲开始啜泣，但唐说，她做了一件令人惊讶的事。她问他为什么难过。她说，你应该高兴，因为孩子正在用完整的脸看着上帝。唐预料到了指责和愤怒。相反，他遇到了一位深深依赖信仰的母亲。唐说，她被孩子现在已经修复、美丽并与上帝同在的想法所安慰。萨尔瓦多终于平静了。唐盯着母亲。
He was speechless, not just because of what she'd said, but because he was struck by another thought. The mother didn't know this, but Salvador's face was not repaired. He died before the surgery was complete. What would the mother say when she saw her son at the funeral? Again, the medical protocol was clear. Don had to turn the body over to Salvador's mother. But he felt he couldn't bring himself to do this. It would only compound the first tragedy. He conferred with his team about finishing the surgery on Salvador. I said it's against the law, but I think in this case, we should. The rest of the team unanimously agreed. The little boy was brought back from the morgue.
他哑口无言，不仅是因为她所说的话，还因为他被另一个想法击中了。母亲不知道这一点，但萨尔瓦多的脸并没有修复。他在手术完成前就死了。母亲在葬礼上看到儿子时会说什么？同样，医疗规程很明确。唐必须把尸体交给萨尔瓦多的母亲。但他觉得他无法做到这一点。这只会加剧第一场悲剧。他与他的团队商量关于完成萨尔瓦多的手术。我说这违反法律，但我认为在这种情况下，我们应该这样做。团队的其他成员一致同意。小男孩被从太平间带了回来。
The child came back on a body bag, and we did the whole thing as if the child was awake. I interviewed Don several times for the story. I pushed hard to understand why he decided to operate on Salvador. What were you telling yourself again emotionally that made you change your mind, that made you say yes I recognize is a risk but I have to do this. I thought this is what I what I am for. This is my purpose. And you said it's worth it standing there and I couldn't say no again. I didn't. I couldn't. But I made it. I said that. Let's go ahead and do the case. I didn't have any second thoughts. I emotionally, I figured out that this is what I should do.
孩子被装在尸袋里带了回来，我们就像孩子醒着一样完成了整个过程。我为这个故事采访了唐好几次。我努力去理解为什么他决定给萨尔瓦多做手术。你当时在情感上对自己说了什么，让你改变了主意，让你说是的，我承认这是一个风险，但我必须这样做。我想这就是我存在的意义。这是我的目的。你说站在那里是值得的，我不能再说不。我没有。我不能。但我做到了。我说过那个。让我们继续做这个病例。我没有任何犹豫。在情感上，我想通了，这就是我应该做的。
Don still thinks about Salvador has thought about him thousands of times over the years. He's turned the case over in his head in every possible way. I asked him over and over whether he felt regret. No. Well, I... of course I do. Of course I do. Yes, I do. I mean, you said just a minute ago it was a mistake.
唐仍然会想到萨尔瓦多，多年来已经想过他成千上万次了。他在脑海中以各种可能的方式翻来覆去地思考这个案例。我一遍又一遍地问他是否感到后悔。不。嗯，我……我当然感到后悔。我当然感到后悔。是的，我感到后悔。我的意思是，你刚才说这是一个错误。
But I don't have, I don't, I don't, I'm not whipping myself. Not whipping himself, Don says, because he was trying to do the right thing. That's the reason he decided to operate. That's the reason he completed the surgery after the child was dead. What was more important than being on the right side of the law? Doing the right thing. By the mother and by the child. Yes, yeah.
但我没有，我没有，我没有，我没有在鞭笞自己。唐说，没有鞭笞自己，因为他是在试图做正确的事。这就是他决定手术的原因。这就是他在孩子死后完成手术的原因。有什么比站在法律正确的一边更重要？做正确的事。对母亲和孩子。是的，是的。
No, you must always do the right thing. That is the highest priority over all different laws and commandments or any of that thing. You have to do the right thing. The day after Salvador died, Don Laab was back in the operating room. There were more children waiting for surgery. He remembers looking out the windows of the sky, it was, he says, a perfect, asuar blue. At 10.30, the time when Salvador was to be buried, everyone on the team felt silent and paused. There was no sound except for the whoosh of the Anasthesia machine.
不，你必须永远做正确的事。这是高于所有不同法律和戒律或任何类似事物的最高优先级。你必须做正确的事。萨尔瓦多去世后的第二天，唐·劳布回到了手术室。还有更多的孩子在等待手术。他记得看着窗外的天空，他说，那是一种完美的、蔚蓝的颜色。在 10 点 30 分，萨尔瓦多将被埋葬的时间，团队中的每个人都感到沉默并停了下来。除了麻醉机的呼呼声外，没有任何声音。
When we think of foxes and hedgehogs, it's completely understandable that we want the best of both worlds. We love bold visionaries who take big risks except when the risks don't work. At moments like that, we prefer the visionaries to be more cautious, filled with a little self-doubt. Now people don't always fall neatly into one camp or the other. Some of us can be both fox and hedgehog. We can think and dream big, but also change course, adapt to circumstances. But it may be that we can't have our cake and eat it too.
当我们想到狐狸和刺猬时，我们想要两全其美是完全可以理解的。我们喜欢敢于承担巨大风险的大胆梦想家，除非风险没有奏效。在那种时刻，我们更希望梦想家更谨慎，充满一点自我怀疑。现在人们并不总是整齐地落入一个阵营或另一个阵营。我们中的一些人既可以是狐狸也可以是刺猬。我们可以思考和梦想宏大，但也可以改变方向，适应环境。但可能我们无法鱼与熊掌兼得。
If we won the visionary Steve Jobs who helped usher in the age of the iPhone, we might also get the tyrannical CEO who nearly ran Apple computers into the ground in the 1980s. It's odd to think of Gandhi and Napoleon and Churchill and Mao in the same breath, but they are cut from the same cloth of Messianic vision. It's easy not to like the kind of people who create history's greatest failures, but it turns out they're also the people who produce our greatest triumphs. This week's show was produced by Jenny Schmidt and edited by Tara Boyle. Our team includes Raina Cohen, Parts Shah, Laura Quarelle and Thomas Liu. The music in today's show was composed by Rampteen Arablui. Our unsung hero this week is another hedgehog and another Don. Donald Drake was a colleague and friend of mine at
如果我们赢得了那位引领了iPhone时代的远见卓识的史蒂夫·乔布斯，我们也可能会得到那位在20世纪80年代差点让苹果电脑公司倒闭的暴君式首席执行官。把甘地、拿破仑、丘吉尔和毛泽东相提并论听起来很奇怪，但他们都是同一类具有救世主愿景的人。我们很容易不喜欢那些制造了历史上最大失败的人，但事实证明，他们也是创造我们最大成就的人。本周的节目由珍妮·施密特制作，塔拉·博伊尔编辑。我们的团队成员包括雷娜·科恩、帕茨·沙阿、劳拉·夸雷尔和托马斯·刘。今天节目的音乐由兰普廷·阿拉布鲁伊创作。我们本周的无名英雄是另一位刺猬型人物，也是另一位唐。唐纳德·德雷克是我多年前在
the Philadelphia Inquire many years ago. He taught me many things about writing and storytelling. We even wrote a play together. Don died shortly after this episode first aired. I'll never forget all that he taught me. For more hidden brain, please follow us on Facebook and Twitter. If you like this episode, please share it with one friend. We're always looking for new people to discover hidden brain. I'm Shankar Vidantum, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
费城问询报工作时的同事和朋友。他教会了我许多关于写作和讲故事的知识。我们甚至还一起写过一部剧本。在本期节目首次播出后不久，唐就去世了。我永远不会忘记他教给我的一切。想了解更多关于《隐藏的大脑》的信息，请在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们。如果你喜欢这一集，请分享给一位朋友。我们一直在寻找新听众来发现《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆，这是美国国家公共电台。目前这一集还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。